And we're talking about just receiving point, point, point.
That's really all it is, because we're not really running anywhere.
The hands are doing the running, and the ball is taking flight.
And it's in a grid of about 6-7 meters.
I'm not saying that we're butchering it, but we're getting used to it.
I'm running you through all the coaching points on how to do this
before we expand this a little bit.
Alright, we'll go for another set.
Questions?
Holding, holding, holding.
Stay square, stay square, stay square.
Hold on. You guys on the end, fall in behind here.
Fall in behind here, so we're only going to have five.
Ready?
That's it, Ricky.
Get right here. Good.
Nice.
Good.
Yep.
Nice.
Good.
Look at your cone, Look at your channel.
What's your channel?
Yep.
Nice!
Get it, get it, get it.
Nice, Rob.
Come back.
Hold on.
Yeah, that'll cover.
Good.
OK.
Go that way.
A three-meter pass.
Yeah.